c'est la comédienne française qui
s'exporte le mieux à l'international
isabelle huppert la plus grande ambition
août à seulement 25 ans l'actrice
remporté un prix d'interprétation à
cannes pour violette nozière sa première
collaboration avec le réalisateur claude
chabrol que pensez vous de ce prix
d'interprétation féminine suis très
contente wazi il est là déjà et claude
chabrol claude chabrol mais je suis très
contente je partage ce prix avec lui
soit éveillé pour beaucoup trois ans
plus tard retour à cannes pour un
deuxième film américain et pas n'importe
lequel la porte du paradis de michael
cimino j'étais tout en cire de maisons
closes si étrange que cela puisse
paraître est là et je devais aussi
monter à cheval faire du patin à
roulettes apprendre à danser la valse
tir au pistolet conduire une carriole
enfin pas tout à fait mon genre au début
des années 80 l'actrice tourne avec la
crème du cinéma européen joseph losey
mauro bolognini marco ferreri vous ne
croyez pas que c'est terriblement
dangereux de commencer une carrière en
ayant tellement de prix est tellement de
festivals j'en ai porté le jeune luke
s'est pas beaucoup j'espère que j'en
aurai d'autres c'est le cas six ans plus
tard à la mostra de venise cette fois
pour une affaire de femmes un film
réalisé par son éternel complice claude
chabrol
2001 première collaboration avec un
autre de ses cinéastes fétiches
l'autrichien michael haneke grâce à son
rôle de professeur austère et névrosée
dans la pianiste elle devient la
première actrice française primée à
cannes lors de deux éditions différentes
avec quelqu'un comme lui on a la
possibilité de
véritablement composer un personnage
d'échapper un peu ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'effet miroir qu'on trouve
nécessairement dans son propre pays on
est toujours on finit toujours par se
répéter un petit peu soi même parce que
les gens vous connaissent c'est très
bien quinze ans plus tard l'actrice
gravi encore un échelon avec elle de
paul verhoeven dans un rôle ambigu une
femme d'affaires violée dans sa villa à
un inconnu masqué aucune actrice
américaine n'avait voulu de ce rôle une
femme pervers sadomasochistes plutôt que
d'en faire une tragédie elle décide d'en
faire un
un événement dont elle peut
tirer quelque chose
isabelle huppert
[Applaudissements]
elle décroche de golden globe de la
meilleure actrice dans un rôle
dramatique
un fait rarissime pour une comédienne
française le réalisateur de basic in stx
ne tarit pas d'éloges sur la star une
actrice formidable chef d'une unité au
cas que je connaissais pas j'ai jamais
vu ça donne des choses au film qui
n'était pas la dernière consécration
date en 2020
le new york times désigné isabelle
huppert comme la deuxième meilleure
comédienne du 21e siècle juste derrière
denzel washington
[Musique]